Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein außerplanmäßiges Video.
Ich weiß ihr könnt das Thema mittlerweile nicht mehr hören
aber das Thema ist so präsent und es betrifft uns alle.
Daher ein außerplanmäßiges Corona-Überlebenstipps Video
im Bereich Ernährung weil das ist ja hier ein Back- und Kochkanal und gerade wenn es ums Kochen geht
fragen mich immer viele: "Was soll ich jetzt machen wenn ich keine frischen Zutaten mehr zuhause habe
und wir in Quarantäne sind?"
Ich muss dazu sagen, dass die Behörden sagen, dass die Einkaufsversorgung ja gegeben ist in Deutschland.
Aber trotzdem bin ich der Meinung man sollte jetzt nicht für 3 Teile alle 3 Tage zum Supermarkt rennen
eben damit man andere nicht ansteckt und damit man die Älteren und die Immunschwachen nicht gefährdet.
Und einfach mal zuhause bleiben!
Was gibt's denn schöneres als einfach mal in seinen eigenen vier Wänden bleiben?
Ich habe z.B. die ganzen Schränke hier letztens ausgemistet.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt aber mal so meinen  10-Tages-Plan.
Und ihr braucht keine frischen Zutaten! Das einzige was ihr an frischen Zutaten benötigt sind Kartoffeln,
Zwiebeln, dann habe ich noch Ingwer und Knoblauch. Aber das sind auch Zutaten, die sehr lange halten.
Eier habe ich jetzt auch mit dabei, die halten ja auch in der Regel ziemlich lange
und ihr könnt das Rezept mit den Eiern ja auch gerne am Anfang machen.
Und jetzt starte ich einfach mal!
10 Tage Corona-Quarantäne, was sollen wir essen?
An Tag 1 habe ich mir überlegt macht ihr euch ganz einfach Spinat-Lasagne,  da könnt ihr -
ich hab das Rezept natürlich auch schon online.
Ihr könnt dann einfach z.B. statt Sahne Milch nehmen, haltbare Milch, haltbare Sahne in Tetrapaks
und dann seid ihr eigentlich ganz gut versorgt. Die schmeckt lecker, hält lange satt
und Spinat ist eigentlich so ein Allrounder, der einfach immer gut schmeckt.
An Tag #2 habe ich mir gedacht gibt's einen bunten Gemüseauflauf mit Würstchen.
Der ist super interessant für Kinder weil die sehen dieses Bunte, die sehen die Würstchen...
und wenn ihr keinen Käse zum Überbacken habt, dann macht das Ganze einfach un-überbacken,
das schmeckt auch super gut! Rezept wie gesagt verlinke ich euch auch in die Infobox.
Kommen wir zum Tag #3: türkische Linsensuppe!
Das ist so der Allrounder wenn ihr einfach Hunger habt, wenn ihr satt bleiben möchtet.
Wenn ihr z.B. keine Möhren da habt, einfach weglassen.
Wenn ihr kein Paprikamark da habt, einfach nur Tomatenmark nehmen.
Also es gibt total viele Varianten.
Und auch das Rezept habe ich schon vor längerer Zeit für euch abgefilmt.
Mein Tipp: unbedingt Zitronensaft da reingeben, ist auch noch mal gut für's Immunsystem!
Und Linsensuppe gerne auch für 2 Tage vorbereiten, also schon mal ein bisschen mehr zubereiten.
Wir sind angekommen am 4. Tag, da gibt's Eierragout!
Eierragout, das ist ein Rezept, das habe ich gemacht,
da sind wir frisch in die Wohnung eingezogen. Erinnerst du dich?
(H: Das war eines der ersten Rezepte, ne?)
Eines der ersten Rezepte hier in dieser Küche!
Weil wir hatten auch nichts im Kühlschrank, genauso wie jetzt!
Man hatte nichts frisches da, wir waren im Umzugsstress,
ich hab Eierragout gemacht und dazu gab's Reis und das hat satt gehalten,
das war mega lecker. Eier: eine gute Proteinquelle! Hält sowieso immer mega lange satt
also gerne mal das Rezept abchecken und nachmachen!
(H: Oder auch für Leute, die einfach Hamstereinkauf gemacht haben
und zu viele Eier haben und dann nicht mehr checken: "Ok, was mach ich mit den Eiern jetzt?")
Bingo! Hamza, 100 Punkte!
Genau, es kann ja sein, dass ihr zu viele Eier eingekauft habt,
also unbedingt Eierragout mit Reis machen, könnt ihr auch mit Nudeln machen!
Jetzt geht's wieder in die türkische Ecke: Cig Köfte!
Für Cig Köfte braucht man eigentlich kaum frische Zutaten.
Wenn ihr keine Petersilie da habt: einfach weglassen!
Petersilie gibt's aber mittlerweile auch tiefgekühlt!
Und Cig Köfte ist so ein Mix, so ein fester Mix aus Bulgur (also aus Weizen).
Habe ich hier und das habe ich auch immer da.
Und ihr könnt das - eigentlich isst man das ja auch wieder mit Zitrone, mit ein bisschen Granatapfelsirup
und mit frischem Blattsalat, man umhüllt das in Blattsalat.
Falls ihr den aber nicht da habt weil wir eben keine frischen Zutaten haben, dann einfach
Wraps nehmen und in Wraps einrollen. Mega lecker hält auch sehr sehr lange satt.
Tag 6, die Woche ist fast überstanden!
Heute gibt's Tortellini-Auflauf. Super schnelles Rezept, auch sehr beliebt bei Kindern.
Und Tortellini gibt's auch in der gekühlten Variante.
Die finde ich leckerer wenn man sie nicht gerade frisch macht
oder die gibt's natürlich auch in der ungekühlten Variante. Wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt,
dann nehmt die aus dem Kühlregal und da halten sie sich ja auch über mehrere Wochen.
Tag #7: Es gibt Gemüseauflauf!
Einfach Tiefkühlgemüse nehmen, haltbare Milch, haltbare Sahne.
Wenn ihr wieder mal keinen Käse habt, einfach nicht überbacken.
Rezept ist wie immer in der Infobox verlinkt.
Und jetzt mein All-Time Favorite: Thunfisch Nudeln!
In 11min zubereitet! Das heißt wenn ihr mal keine Zeit habt weil ihr zuhause total zugange seid,
ihr macht Home Office, ihr räumt auf.. Ihr denkt euch: "Oh Gott, ich muss ja noch kochen!"
Dann macht die 11 Minuten Thunfisch Nudeln!
Und Hamza das Rezept müssen wir unbedingt noch mal neu abfilmen!
Weil das Rezept ist schon ein bisschen älter.
(H: Ich find das passt auch jetzt, wir können das in den nächsten Tagen neu abfilmen.)
Ja das machen wir. Wir drehen das nochmal neu.
(H: Passt zum Thema grade auch.)
Das passt mega zum Thema weil: Thunfisch in Konserven habt ihr ja eigentlich immer da
(also ich zumindest) und wenn ihr wie im Rezept angegeben kein Crème fraîche habt
oder Frischkäse weil das auch frische Zutaten sind, dann ganz einfach passierte Tomaten nehmen.
Sehr sehr lecker, da könnt ihr dann auch wieder Mais etc. hinzufügen
und habt dann richtig leckere Nudeln mit Thunfisch-Soße.
So, das waren jetzt 8 Vorschläge auf meinem Kanal, die ich schon online habe
und gleich zeige ich euch noch zwei weitere.
Allerdings kleiner Disclaimer vorab: ich weiß das war jetzt kein Superfood,
keine mega gesunden Rezepte. Auch nicht ungesund, klar.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch Reis durch Vollkornreis ersetzen,
ihr könnt die Nudeln durch Linsennudeln ersetzen etc.
Das ist aber eben das, was in den Supermärkten jetzt am ehesten weg ging
und das, was die meisten in der Vorratskammer haben.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch ein geniales Rezept und zwar machen wir Kartoffelgulasch!
Richtig lecker, auch schnell zubereitet mit wenig Zutaten.
Und die habe ich hier schon teilweise bereit. Und zwar habe ich hier frischen Kurkuma,
Ingwer, dann habe ich Knoblauch und Kartoffeln.
Die Kartoffeln gebe ich jetzt nicht so groß da rein sondern mache sie vorher klein,
dann sind die nämlich auch schneller gar.
So, jetzt geben wir in einen beschichteten Topf zuallererst etwas Öl, dünsten darin den Knoblauch an,
anschließend auch noch Ingwer und Kurkuma, aber auch nur ganz kurz auf mittlerer Stufe!
Danach geben wir Tomatenmark hinzu. Auch schön anrösten, dass die ganzen Röstaromen entstehen.
Und anschließend kommen die Kartoffeln dazu und das Ganze wird mit Gemüsebrühe abgelöscht.
So und danach rühren wir das Ganze, würzen es noch etwas mit Salz und Pfeffer, lassen es aufkochen
und dann braucht es auch nur 8min mit geschlossenem Deckel.
Und dann sind wir auch schon fertig!
Das Ganze ist jetzt sehr dickflüssig, deswegen mache - dickflüssig? Dünnflüssig!
(H: Dünnflüssig!)
Deswegen möchte ich das dickflüssiger haben
und nehme mir hier ein bisschen Mehl, verdünne das mit Wasser und -
(H: Oh Mehl, das ist aber sehr gefragt grade!)
Mehl, Luxusgut! Ein Luxusgut!
(H: Sag das nicht in die Kamera, sonst denkt man wir sind reich!)
Ja, wir haben auch nicht mehr so viel Mehl! Also Einbruch lohnt sich nicht!
Jetzt verrühre ich das und geb' das noch mit rein, lasse das  einmal kurz einkochen
so 1-2min und dann ist es fertig. Ihr könnt das jetzt entweder so essen
oder mit ein bisschen Baguette, mit ein bisschen Brot - sehr lecker! Sehr sehr lecker auf jeden Fall.
Ok angekommen am Tag Numero 10! Ihr habt jetzt 9 Rezeptideen von mir bekommen,
die zehnte kommt jetzt. Und zwar machen wir Couscous. Couscous ist mega lecker
und man kann das total aufwerten. Ich nehme gerne Instant-Couscous, der geht innerhalb von 3min.
Und ich habe jetzt hier zuallererst mal Kichererbsen und grüne Erbsen vorgekocht,
die sind beide aus der Dose gewesen. Die normalen Kichererbsen, die brauchen  ungefähr 5min
und in der letzten Minute gebe ich noch die grünen Erbsen rein und dann ganz einfach abtropfen lassen.
So und jetzt habe ich hier eine beschichtete Pfanne, da habe ich etwas Rapsöl reingegeben
und werd' da jetzt ein bisschen Knoblauch andünsten und gleich gebe ich auch noch Zwiebeln mit dazu.
Und ganz wichtig: nur die mittlere Stufe nehmen damit auch nichts verbrennt. Also nur andünsten!
So jetzt habe ich noch Kurkuma mit dem Wiegemesser richtig schön fein gehackt.
Vorsicht, bei Kurkuma bekommt ihr immer gelbe Hände, da könnt ihr auch Handschuhe z.B. tragen.
Habe ich auch noch ganz kurz angedünstet und dann schon das Wasser mit dazu gegeben.
Das Ganze kocht jetzt, da geben wir jetzt die Kichererbsen und die grünen Erbsen dazu.
Und jetzt ganz wichtig: den Herd ausschalten weil der Instant-Couscous
der gart jetzt nur noch 2min in der Resthitze. So, der Herd ist jetzt aus.
Den Couscous einmal mit dazu, umrühren, den Deckel drauf geben und so 2-3min garen lassen.
So und dazu gibt es bei uns ganz einfach Rinderwürstchen und wenn ihr jetzt noch ein bisschen
Joghurt im Kühlschrank habt, dann gebt das gerne noch mit dazu, das passt nämlich perfekt.
Und ansonsten waren das meine 10 Tipps, die ihr beherzigen könnt wenn ihr z.B.
nichts mega frisches mehr im Kühlschrank habt oder einfach keinen Plan habt was ihr kochen sollt.
Schreibt mir doch gerne in die Kommentare wenn ihr jetzt noch weitere Vorschläge habt.
Schreibt mir doch: Seid ihr in Quarantäne
oder lebt ihr so wie immer und geht raus unter Leute? Das rate ich euch natürlich nicht!
Ansonsten können wir uns gerne auch weiter über das Thema austauschen.
(H: Oder Rezeptvorschläge!)
Ja, oder Rezeptvorschläge!
Weil wir sind ja jetzt auch nur zuhause, wir haben keine Termine draußen..
(H: Nein, wir haben kein Rezept für Toilettenpapier!
Kein Rezept für Toilettenpapier, nein leider.
Tut uns leid!
(H: *lacht*)
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Macht euch nicht verrückt, bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Video. Tschüss!